المترجم: Muna Muhaureq
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
نجد أن معظم الأبحاث
في مجال الهندسة والتكنولوجيا
تتجه نحو كيفية ابتكار وخلق
تقنيات جديدة
بحيث تكون صديقة للبيئة من جانب،
ومن جانب آخر بحيث أن
توفر لنا رفاهية للمجتمع.
ومن هنا بدأت فكرة الشبكات الضوئية
في كيفية تطوير نظام اتصالات
تكون صديق للبيئة من جانب
ومن جانب آخر يحل لنا المشاكل
التي تواجه أنظمة الاتصالات اليوم
هل تتخلوا أنه حاليا لدينا أكثر
من 1.4 بليون برج اتصالات في العالم
وعندنا أكثر من 5 بليون
من أجهزة الهاتف المحمول
الكم الهائل هذا من أجهزة الهاتف المحمول
تعطينا أكثر من 600 تيرابايت
من البيانات التي ترسل في اليوم الواحد
إنها 6 وأربعة عشر صفرا
هذا عدد كبير جدا جدا
لذا نجد أن أنظمة الاتصالات اللاسلكية
أصبحت من أساسيات الحياة،
مثلها مثل الماء والكهرباء
أستخدمها في أي مكان
تستخدم في الحياة العامة، وفي الحياة الخاصة
وحتى في الحياة العملية
ولهذا لنرى أهمية
أنظمة الاتصالات اللاسلكية هذه
التي تقودنا إلى شيء جديد
وهي المشاكل التي تواجه
أنظمة الاتصالات اللاسلكية اليوم
وأحد المشاكل التي تواجه أنظمة
الاتصالات اللاسلكية هي مشكلة السعة
من المعروف عند أغلب الناس
أن أنظمة الاتصالات اللاسلكية
تستخدم الطيف الكهرومغناطيسي
وتستخدم جزء محدود منه
وهي موجات الراديو
وكما هو معروف أن موجات الراديو
عندها مشاكل كثيرة
أحد مشاكلها أنها أقل فعالية
هذا الشيء الأول
الشيء الثاني أننا لو قارناها
من حيث عرض النطاق
سنجدها صغيرة جدا مقارنة
بالأجزاء الأخرى من الطيف الكهرومغناطيسي
الشيء الثالث من حيث التكلفة
هي غالية جدا جدا
لأنك إذا أردت أن ترسل
عبر موجات كهرومغناطيسية
في النهاية ستحتاج أن تحجز عرض نطاق
وعرض النطاق محتاج لرخصة
والرخصة تحتاج لمال
كل ماذكرناه لاتتفق مع متطلبات العصر
لأنظمة الاتصالات التماثلية
الشيء الثاني هي عبارة عن الكفاءة
عندما أقول كفاءة، أحددها من أي منظور؟
أنظرها من ناحية القدرة المستهلكة
بالنسبة لأي محطة
وأجد أن القدرة الاستهلاكية لأي محطة
تستهلك معظمها في التبريد
لذا نجد الكفاءة فقط 5%
وتعتبر هذه مشكلة كبيرة جدا جدا
الشيء الثالث هي عبارة عن التوفر
الكل يتفق معي أن الضوء
ليس متوفر في الطائرات
ليس متوفر تحت الماء
ليس متوفر في المستشفيات
وغيرها من الأماكن
وهذه أيضا تعتبر مشكلة
الشيء الرابع هي عبارة عن الأمان
عندما أقول الأمان، أحددها من أي منظور؟
من المعلوم أن موجات الراديو
عندها المقدرة على اختراق الجدران
فبالتالي يمكن لأي شخص
القدرة على الوصول للشبكة
وهذه قد تكون مشكلة كبيرة جدا
وهي عبارة عن الأربع أشياء الأساسية
ولكن في الجانب الآخر
لدينا 14 بليون من مصابيح الإنارة
التي تزودنا بالضوء
والضوء عبارة عن جزء
من الطيف الكهرومغناطيسي
لننظر على ماذا يحتوي الطيف الكهرومغناطيسي
أشعة الجاما الخطيرة جدا للإنسان
أشعة الإكس والتي تستخدم
بشكل محدود فقط في المستشفيات
الأشعة الفوق بنفسجية
تستخدم فقط في بعض الأمور
وهي خطيرة أيضا إذا تعرض لها الإنسان
الأشعة تحت الحمراء تستخدم
في أنظمة الاتصالات اللاسلكية
لكن بمحدودية
الشيء الرابع هي عبارة عن (موجة الراديو)
مثلما ذكرنا الأربع أشياء المتواجدة فيها
في الوسط هو عبارة عن الضوء المرئي
والضوء موجود حولنا منذ آلاف السنين
بل هو العامل الأساسي
في ارتقاء ونماء البشرية
ليس هذا فقط بالإضافة
إلى سلامة الاستخدام
ممكن نستخدمه أيضا
في أنظمة الاتصالات اللاسلكية
هذه فقط ماعندنا
لنقارن بين موجات الراديو
ومابين الضوء من حيث عرض النطاق
نجد أن الضوء أكبر من موجات
الراديو بعشرة ألف مرة
تخيلوا معي أن يكون لنا
عرض النطاق مضاعف عشرة ألف مرة
وهو عرض نطاق إضافي
لنرى هذا الشيء، هل هذا فقط مالدينا؟
عرض نطاق إضافي فقط؟
لذلك قلنا أن لدينا 1.4 بليون
من أبراج الاتصالات المنتشرة في العالم
وحاليا لدينا عشرة آلاف مرة
من عرض النطاق المتوفر لدينا أيضا
معناه عدد الهيكل الأساسي الذي لدينا
سيكون عبارة عن 14بليون من مصابيح الإنارة
تخيلوا معي 14 بليون من مصابيح الإنارة
نستخدمها للإنارة ونستخدمها للاتصالات
لكن في هذا اللحظة يدور سؤالين
السؤال الأول: كيف ممكن
أن نستخدم الضوء المتوفر عندنا
لعملية الاتصال؟
الحل بسيط والإجابة على السؤال أبسط
كل ما سنعمله هو استبدال
مصابيح الإنارة الموجودة لدينا هذه
بتكنولوجيا جديدة وهي عبارة عن
الصمام الثنائي الباعث للضوء
وهي عبارة عن جهاز إلكتروني
عنده القدرة على اشعاع الضوء
وعنده خاصية جميلة جدا جدا
وهي عبارة أنه
يفتح ويغلق بسرعة كبيرة جدا
وهذه هي الخاصية الأساسية
التي تقوم عليها التكنولوجيا
لنرى ماذا يعني ذلك
قلنا أن الضوء المشع فيه
الإغلاق والفتح بسرعة كبيرة جدا
فبالتالي سينتج بيانات متدفقة
في صورة حيز صفري
كيف يعني تكون في صورة حيز صفري؟
بكل بساطة لنفترض أن
الصمام الثنائي الباعث للضوء مقفل
فإنه سيمثل لنا صفراً
ولو كان النطاق مفتوح سيمثل واحد
وكما يعلم معظم الناس
أن أغلب البيانات الموجودة حالياً
هي عبارة عن بيانات رقمية
أي أننا نمثلها في صورة صفر وواحد
فبالتالي أستطيع استخدام الصمام
الثنائي الباعث للضوء كوسيلة للاتصال
لكن السؤال الثاني هو: هل استبدال
الصمام الثنائي الباعث للضوء
بالمصابيح الموجودة، هل هو كافٍ؟
ليوفر لنا وسيلة اتصال؟
أكيد لا. ولكي نجيب على هذا السؤال سنرى
جئت هنا بنموذج مصغر يوضح
تكنولوجيا الشبكات الضوئية
أو يوضح جزء مصغرمن التكنولوجيا
النموذج يتكون من مصباح مكتبي
أضفنا لها التقنية الجديدة،
الصمام الثنائي الباعث للضوء
بالإضافة إلى برنامج صممناه
على أنه يقوم بالمعالجة
يساعدنا في إرسال واستقبال البيانات
بالإضافة إلى جهاز حساس للضوء
ومهمته أنه يستطيع استقبال البيانات
ويحولها مرة أخرى لإشارة كهربائية
أستطيع التعامل معها وعمل
المعالجة اللازمة
نتمنى في المستقبل أن نستطيع
أن ندمج حساس الضوء
في الأجهزة الذكية، في الهواتف الذكية
ليس هذا فقط، نستطيع استخدام
الكاميرا الثانوية الموجودة في الهاتف الذكي
على أساس أنها تستشعر الضوء
أو تستشعر التغير في الضوء
لنرى ماذا سيحدث لو فتحنا الزر
أي شخص لو رأى المصباح
سيتوقعه مصباح عادي
مستخدمة لغرض من أغراض الإنارة
لكن لايتوقع أن نفس المصباح
الموجود حاليا لدينا
استخدم لكي يرسل البيانات
من الجهاز الأول إلى الجهاز الثاني
مثلما سنرى
كما نرى أن البرنامج
مكون من أربع أجزاء رئيسية
الجزء الأول وهو عبارة عن الرسالة الضوئية
لإمكانية إرسال رسالة
والجزء الثاني عبارة عن رسالة ضوئية
لامكانية إرسال صورة
والجزء الأخير عبارة عن
الرسالة الضوئية الصوتية
لامكانية إرسال صوت
بالإضافة إلى الجزء الأخير
وهو عبارة عن الاختيار
وهو لإمكانية إما إقفال أو فتح الجهاز
وهو مثل الخيار الموجود في البلوتوث
لننظر للجزء الأول وهي الرسالة الضوئية
ذلك جانب المرسل
لنتكلم عن الجانب الذي للمستقبل
يتكون من أربع أشياء رئيسية
وهو امكانية استقبال رسالة
أو امكانية استقبال صورة
أو امكانية استقبال صوت
بالإضافة إلى امكانية قفل أو فتح الجهاز
لنرى عند إرادة استقبال رسالة
سنختار "رسالة ضوئية"
ستفتح نافذة مكونة من جزئين رئيسيين
من زرين رئيسيين
وهما عبارة عن "العودة أو الاستلام"
"العودة" هو للنافذة الرئيسية
أو "الاستلام" لاستقبال البيانات
لنرى، نجد أن النافذة هنا أيضا
تتكون من جزئين رئيسيين
وهو عبارة عن" العودة والإرسال"
نريد نرسل رسالة..
ونختار "الارسال"
نلاحظ أنه أعطانا إشعار
أنه تم إرسال البيانات
لنرى جانب المستقبل
سنضغط على زر "الاستلام"
سنلاحظ أنه تم استقبال البيانات بنجاح
نرجع للنافذة الرئيسية إذا افترضنا
أننا نريد استقبال صورة
نضغط على زر نجد النافذة
تتكون من ثلاثة أزرار رئيسية
هي عبارة عن "الاستلام والعرض والعودة"
لننظر إلى جانب المرسل
ونحاول نرسل
نجد النافذة لما نضغط على "رسالة ضوئية"
تظهر لنا نافذة مكونة من أربع أجزاء
الزر الأول المراد إرسال صورة
الزر الثاني للإرسال والثالث لعرض
الصورة المراد إرسالها
لنرى وعلى سبيل المثال نضغط على "بحث"
نختار مثلا أي صورة من الصور الموجودة
تفتح نافذة لتحديد المسار
الموجود فيها الصورة
نختارمثلاُ على سبيل المثال هذه الصورة
نضغط "فتح" ونختار "عرض"
سنجد الصورة المحددة..
نلاحظ أن الصورة المراد إرسالها
نضغط على زر "عرض"
لكي نستطيع إرسال الصورة نضغط على "إرسال"
في هذه اللحظة سنلاحظ أن الضوء
حدث له تغيير بسيط
وهو تردد الفتح والإقفال
لكن لانستطيع ملاحظته بالعين المجردة
لأنه بسرعة عالية جدا جدا
نلاحظ أنه أعطانا إشعار في جانب المرسل
أن البيانات تم إرسالها هنا
مثلما نلاحظ هنا
لننظر في جانب المستقبل نجد أنه
سنضغط على "استلام"
نلاحظ أنه أعطانا تنبيه
أنه تم استقبال البيانات
في مربع الحوار الصغير
سنختار عرض البيانات
سنجدها نفس الصورة التي أرسلت
من الجانب المرسل الموجود هنا
نأتي للجزء الأخير وهو عبارة
عن إرسال الصوت
نعود للنافذة الرئيسية في جانب المرسل
ونضغط باختيار "الصوت"
سنجد النافذة أيضا تتكون من أربع أجزاء
من أهمها الجزء المهم وهو رابط التسجيل
نحدد فيه طول التسجيل
على سبيل المثال نسجل لثانيتين
وأبدأ التسجيل وأحاول أسجل
على سبيل المثال: أهلاً بالجميع
أهلاً بالجميع
سنجد بعد أن سجلنا يعطينا إشعار
بأن التسجيل انتهى وتوقف
لو نريد نسمع التسجيل.. (يردد التسجيل)
الخطوة الثانية: نأتي لجانب المستقبل
نرجع للنافذة الرئيسية
نفتح الرسالة الضوئية الصوتية
والنافذة مكونة من ثلاثة أجزاء
هنا سنرسل في جانب المرسل
نضغط على زر "إرسال"
عند الضغط على زر"إرسال"
سنجد تغيير بسيط جدا
لا نلاحظه بالعين
نتيجة للسرعة العالية جدا
نجد أنه أعطانا إشعار بأن البيانات
تم إرسالها كما الظاهر
نأتي لجانب المستقبل ونضغط "استلام"
نلاحظ أنه أعطاني إشعار بأن البيانات
تم استقبالها كما نلاحظ
بعد ذلك اضغط على زر "فتح التسجيل"
(التسجيل: أهلا بالجميع)
كما تشاهدون
لنرى أحد التطبيقات المهمة جدا والمتوقعة
بالنسبة لتكنولوجيا
كتكنولوجيا الشبكات الضوئية
أحد التطبيقات التي ممكن توقعها
ونتطبق فيها تكنولوجيا الشبكات الضوئية
هي أولا للأماكن التي تحتاج إرشادات
أو أماكن نحتاج فيها معلومات
عن حاجة محددة مثل المتاحف
ممكن نستخدم المصابيح الموجودة
في المتاحف لشيئين
الشيء الأول للإنارة والثانية لتعطينا
معلومات عن التحفة الأثرية
لنرى التطبيق الثاني وهي عبارة عن
إشارات المرور الضوئية
كيف يمكننا استخدام تقنيتنا هنا؟
ممكن هنا نوفر وسيلة للاتصال بين السيارات
عن طريق استخدام المصابيح الموجودة فيها
ومابين السيارة والإشارة الضوئية
على أساس أن تزودنا إشارة المرور
بالمعلومات اللازمة لكي تنظم حركة السير
والتطبيق الثالث في الطائرات
بالنسبة للطائرات وقطاع الصناعة
فإن أحد مشاكل موجات الراديو
أن بها مشكلة التداخل
وهذي عبارة عن مشكلة كبيرة جدا جدا
بحيث أنها تؤثر على الأجهزة الإلكترونية
وفي مناطق كالطائرات أو المواقع الصناعية
المسألة قد تسبب مشاكل كارثية لأنه
تستخدم أجهزة إلكترونية حساسة
الشيء الثالث من التطبيقات المتوقعة
هي التطبيقات تحت الماء
لأنه من مشاكل موجات الراديو
أن الماء يمتصها
فبالتالي ممكن استخدام الضوء كبديل
لموجات الراديو في تطبيقات ماتحت الماء
لننظر في المستشفيات فمعروف
الأضرار الصحية التي تنتج من موجات الراديو
فبالتالي ممكن الضوء هنا
يكون بديل للموجات
في النهاية ذكرنا الأربع أشياء الأساسية
وهي عبارة عن الكفاءة
والسعة والتوفر والأمان
بالنسبة للشبكات الضوئية كسعة،
قلنا أن لدينا 14بليون من المصابيح
ممكن أكيد تكون أحد الحلول
المتواجدة للسعة
التي تواجهنا في أنظمة اللاسلكية
الشيء الثاني من حيث الكفاءة،
نحن نستخدم المصباح باعث مشع
لاحظوا معي مستخدمين بطارية عادية
على أساس نستطيع تشغيل
المصباح الثنائي المشع
فهو من حيث استهلاك الطاقة اقتصادي جدا
الشي الثالث هو الوفرة،
والضوء متوفر في كل مكان
حاليا الضوء حولنا
والشيء الرابع هو الأمان
بالنسبة للأمان فالمعروف
أن الضوء لا يخترق الحواجز
فبالتالي متى ما وجد الضوء وجدت البيانات
وهذه الأمور الأساسية
ونتمنى في المستقبل بدل يكون عندنا
14 بليون من المصابيح العادية
أن يكون لدين 14 بليون من الشبكات الضوئية
مع عالم أخضر ومشرق ونظيف
وشكرا
(تصفيق)